[Musique]
salut mais vous êtes rail ce plan vise
un bon jour les saves à la hanche droite
n'est sarah merci grand mur et quoi j'ai
amené une conquête 1
je travaille beaucoup il n'est tout le
temps en déplacement avec des clients et
moi et là rabat joie de service qui va
faire des plannings jeté un bloc alors
dix mille souvent en voyage un bon clip
apport le boulot on arrête lever la main
si vous trouvez ça foire lé deal n'a
rien à voir avec toi c'est un gentil
gars à un père génial
samedi c'est sa nature les mâles doit
lutter s'ils veulent dominer et féconde
et toutes les familles
[Musique]
peut-être que mon mari il s'intéresse
pris à moi impossible
c'est une femme est au sommet de sa
beauté entre l'âge de 35 et de 39 ans en
fait il me reste plein de moi félix
antoine dire que tu travailles beaucoup
et plein de trucs on voit ton mari
devrait générer le sol que tu pourrais
p6 conduit mal c'est important que tout
seul et si jamais on découvrait que
digne tout simplement débordés je crois
qu'on devrait tenter depuis la tour
il vaudrait mieux que tulle ou en
actions c'est ça ce que tu appelles être
incognito
bien placé dans ce palace qui te trompe
c'est celui qu'elle puisse de sortie il
y en a sur trois rues
est-ce que c'est revenir et d'avoir
l'air juste un peu moins enthousiaste
parce qu'il s'agit de ma vie là et elle
était en train de tomber en ruine
je sais pas pourquoi les femmes pour les
chirurgies esthétiques et rose sommes
dans ton genre
je les préfère avec les pièces d'origine
oui et quelle que soit la marque et le
modèle
merci je vais prendre ça comme un
compliment
il y en a bien deux pros j'ai eu peur